MOBILIZATION AND HISTORY.
THE USE OF TESTING IN THE U.S.
NOW.
MORE CITIZENS OF THE CORONAVIRUS
THAN ANY OTHER COUNTRY ON EARTH.
AND OF DATA IS HOW MUCH PROGRESS
MADE, SENIOR ADVISOR THE
PRESIDENT AND JARED KUSHNER.
THE PRESIDENT’S NUMBERS TODAY,
I’M IMPRESSED.
TELL US WHERE WE ARE.
THIS IS SOMETHING WE HAVE MORE
ITERATION OF TESTING APPROVED.
HOW MANY TEST CAN WE GET DONE IN
MAY AND JUNE AND HOW DOES THAT
HELP REOPEN THE COUNTRY?
THANK YOU, SEAN.
THE PRESIDENT IS IN THE
OVAL OFFICE WORKING LATE AND HE
WAS QUITE PLEASED WITH THE
PROGRESS WE MADE TODAY TO GIVE
AMERICANS THE TOOLS THAT WE NEED
TO OPEN UP SAFELY.
TESTING IS A MAJOR COMPONENT OF
THAT.
WE PASSED 9.3 MILLION TESTS.
WE ARE BEST TESTING, 394,711
TESTS.
COMPARE THAT TO 60 DAYS AGO,
BASICALLY MARCH 11TH, WE DID
3,748.
THAT IS OVER 100 TIMES INCREASE
IN TESTING FROM WHERE WE WERE 60
DAYS.
THE RAMP-UP CONTINUES TO BE
EXTRAORDINARY, AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP CONTINUES TO PUT
THE FULL FORCE OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT BEHIND TO DO
EVERYTHING WE NEED TO GET ALL
THE RESOURCES WE NEED TO
MINIMIZE THE DAMAGE THAT IS
BEING COST THEM BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW BY THE VIRUS AND TO GET OUR
COUNTRY OPEN.
HE IS THE DEFENSE WHO CREATED
VENTILATORS, 30,000 VENTILATORS
AND THE PRESIDENT IS ON TRACK TO
DO OVER 50,000 VENTILATORS THIS
YEAR.
HE IS DOING SWABS, MASTS, MAKING
THINGS APPEAR IN AMERICA WHICH
IS REALLY GREAT.
AND THAT IS GIVING US THE
ABILITY TO NEED TO MAKE SURE WE
OPEN UP THE COUNTRY SAFELY.
>> Sean: SO ON MARCH 2ND, BOTH
THE GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK,
MAYOR OF NEW YORK, GO OUT ON THE
TOWN.
WE ARE FINE.
THE PRESIDENT WITH COVID-19 AND
WE PROVIDED EVERY VENTILATOR,
MASK, RESPIRATOR, SHIELD, GOWNS,
GLOVES AND THEY SENT THE PEOPLE,
OLD PEOPLE’S HOMES AND DIDN’T
USE TOO THOUSAND BEDS AT THE
JAVITS CENTER AND NEARLY 1,000
BEDS.
WHY?
>> THIS ISN’T ABOUT POINTING
FINGERS, SEAN.
THIS IS AN UNPRECEDENTED
CHALLENGE AND IMPRESSMENT
CHALLENGE FOR THE PRESIDENT,
GOVERNOR, MAYORS.
WE CAME TOGETHER AND WORKED
CLOSELY WITH NEW YORK AND SENT
4,400 VENTILATORS AND MONEY.
WE SENT THEM RESOURCES, PEOPLE,
MASKS.
THE BILL WAS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE GET ALL THE RESOURCES WE
NEEDED TO THE FRONT LINE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
DANGER FROM THE VIRUS GOT WHAT
THEY NEEDED.
THANKFULLY IN NEW YORK AND
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY, ANYONE